>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michael North:
Good morning everyone.
I hope are all ready for
another set of interesting
and insightful presentations
about the history
of science, medicine and books.
It's my pleasure to introduce
Lilla Vekerdy, whom I've known
as a historian and fellow
curator for over 20 years.
Lilla has been head
of special collections
at the Smithsonian
Library since 2008.
Previously, she worked at the
Bernard Becker Medical Library
at Washington University
in St. Louis
as rare book librarian
for 13 years.
Her research interests and
publications are in the history
of medicine and rare
book studies and often
about the overlay
of these two fields.
Her presentation will
discuss and place
in parallel two illustrated
books about science.
The 1495 edition of Johannes de
Ketham's, "Fasciculus Medicine,"
one my favorite early
printed books.
And an artist book from 2004
by Joyce Cutler-Shaw
titled "The Anatomy Lesson."
The first book was the
direct inspirational source
of the second one.
And they were displayed
together at an exhibition
in the Smithsonian Libraries,
science and the artist book.
The comparison of the books
reveals rivaling expressions
of not just two but
three time periods.
Within the Ketham
work, ideas and ideals
from the middle ages
grapple with the renaissance.
And then both eras jointly
appear on oppositional pages
of modern depictions
of the 21st-century artist
book by Joyce Cutler-Shaw.
Intending to untangle
this threefold conundrum,
the presentation
touches on science,
art and poetry, please
welcome Lilla.
[ Applause ]
>> Lilla Vekerdy: Good morning.
Thank you, Michael for
the nice introduction.
And thank you for coming out
on a nice, snowy spring day.
In this presentation,
I will place
in parallel two visually
intriguing rare volumes.
They are closely related
and yet very different.
One is an artistic medical
book from the 15th century.
While the other is a medical
artist book published in 2004.
I will also use images
of selected late
medieval manuscripts
and the artwork of
Andrea Mantegna.
Since we'll be skipping from
book to book, from installation
to illustration, I
tagged each image
within every slide
for reference.
Please watch those small labels.
The first book titled
"Fasciculus Medicine,"
usually spelled with a-e at the
end, in this edition, just an e,
the little bundle of
medicine was printed
by the Gregorius brothers
in Venice in 1495.
Its first edition
published in 1491 is known
as the earliest illustrated
medical texts in print.
And highly regarded for
its artistic qualities.
The book went through
several editions
in different languages
in rapid succession.
We would be looking at the
second Latin edition from 1495,
held in the Dibner Library
of the History of Science
and Technology in the
Smithsonian Libraries.
This relatively small
collection,
with its 35,000 rare
volumes is proud to hold more
than 320 scientific incunabula,
one of which is Ketham's
"Fasciculus Medicine."
The genre of the "Fasciculus"
is typically premodern.
It is a compilation of various
ancient and medieval sources.
The text itself, names Johannes
de Ketham, presumed originally
from Kelkheim, mid-15th
century Venice medical professor
as the compiler.
Recent scholarship, however, has
proven this proposition wrong.
Offering no new proposition,
though.
The question, who compiled
the book is still open.
This doesn't seem to weaken
the established authority
of the work, which
is characterized
in its frontispiece shown here.
The figure at the desk
Andrea Mantegna was professor
of medicine at the
University of Padua
in the middle of
the 15th century.
A well-known physician,
[inaudible],
he is not the compiler
of this book either.
His role here is to represent
authoritative knowledge
in the person of a respected
scholar transcribing,
or maybe translating a text
that lies open on his desk.
He is surrounded by books of
Greek, Roman and Arabic authors.
Most of these books
are medical classics.
On the shelf, left to right are
Aristotle, Hippocrates, Galen,
Avicenna, Aliamte,
Rasis, Masve, and others,
with the author's
names on the covers.
The ornate binding
of the Avicenna volume placed
strategically in the middle
of the shelf refers
to Avicenna's role
as princeps medicorum
throughout centuries.
Pliny, the elders,
"Historia Naturalis" open
on the desk facing
us, is an indication
of the traditional
importance of natural history
in practical therapeutics.
This illustration of the
medical library of Mantegna,
denotes the most
reliable sources according
to contemporary medical
knowledge.
Established as these books
were, their depiction,
on the other hand is inaccurate
by now-a-day standards.
As you see, the artist is
having a bit of a problem
with the rules of perspective.
However, a crucial
moment is denoted here.
The science and art of
drawing the third dimension is
in the making.
The second book in our
discussion is an artist book,
titled "The Anatomy
Lesson" conversations
with Johannes Ketham.
It was published in 2004.
As an artist's book, this volume
features the familiar aspects
of the physical book but
renders its content visually
with the liberty and endless
possibilities of the fine arts.
The result is a piece of
art, which is still a book,
and demonstrates a distinctive
artistically emphasized
relationship between text
and image, form and content.
The author and the artist
of "The Anatomy Lesson"
is Joyce Cutler-Shaw,
an active contemporary
artist among the San
Diego environmentalist.
She started as a
traditional painter,
and later turned to other media.
An artist interested in science,
she is fascinated by the works
of Leonardo da Vinci,
and refers to him
as major inspiration
for her art.
For years, Cutler-Shaw
was artist in residence
at the University of California,
San Diego Medical School.
attended anatomy lab courses,
namely dissections
and drew there.
Drawing is a tool
for the exploration
of the world, she claims.
The first version of "The
Anatomy Lesson" was designed
for the science and the
artist book exhibition
at the Smithsonian
Libraries in 1995.
For this exhibition,
the libraries invited
contemporary artists to choose
and examine famous rare books
from those that Bern Dibner,
engineer, collector and science
historian considered the 200
most significant works in
the history of science.
Inspired by the chosen
old scientific volumes,
each artist created
a modern artist book
to be exhibited together
with the original.
Joyce Cutler-Shaw selected
the 1495 Ketham volume
and with a great amount
of research writing
and artwork her new
anatomy lesson took 10 years
to appear in its final form.
The physical structure of the
two books differ significantly.
The Ketham features
traditional structure.
Full page word cuts and
they face mainly text pages.
On the other hand, the Joyce
Cutler-Shaw book in her book,
each gathering starts
with a half title page,
followed by two descriptive
expects pages.
Which then open up
to a four-panel view.
On the left side
we see facsimiles
from the Ketham volume facing
a new Cutler-Shaw illustration
and a poem written
by her on the right.
The individual segments or
gatherings are bound together,
but act almost like
separate books,
reflecting the originally
disjointed
and only later compiled
content of the Ketham book.
Both books alternate ideas
from two distinct time
periods in different styles.
In the Ketham volume we see
an interplay between medieval
and renaissance elements.
In content, the book
leads directly back
to medieval examples
and sources.
Most of the medical ideas
of the illustrations,
we will see later, are also
tied to the middle ages.
Nevertheless, the artistic style
of the Ketham illustrations
represent predominantly
the renaissance.
Note, the flow of garments.
Both, the long academic ropes,
and the nonacademic short coats.
Some feature here and there,
broken straight lines,
more gothic.
Others handle the curves
easily, more renaissance.
The architectural elements in
the background, nonetheless,
are in pure renaissance form
based on classical example.
Some of the figures involved
Andrea Mantegna contemporary
drawings, as you see the arrows.
Joyce Cutler-Shaw shows the
interplay between renaissance
and modern components
as she places facsimiles
of Ketham illustrations
next to her own.
Her energetic drawing
seems to rebel
against the stiff Ketham images.
In her plates, soulful
modern-day figures appear
with fleeting emotions
and rapid movements.
Occasionally creating the
impression of motion pictures.
Let us now, compare four
pairs of corresponding images
from the two books and see
how different time periods;
the middle ages, the renaissance
and the 21st-century,
are woven into the fabric of the
medical and artistic context.
With this comparison,
I would like to argue
that the 500-year
old book can directly
and beautifully inspired
fresh content about science
and humanity in the
most modern style.
The first image in our
comparison is the vein man.
A familiar character in
most illustrated medical
and surgical texts
from the earliest time.
The lines and words surrounding
the figure point out the veins
and arteries on the human
body for bloodletting,
to cure various disease.
The ancient medical practice
of bloodletting governed
therapeutics in the middle ages
and the renaissance as well.
The Ketham illustration
has numerous examples
in the medieval manuscript
tradition looking almost
like immediate predecessors.
The figures of the vein man are
point dissimilar in the book
and in "The Anatomy Lesson."
The renaissance artists
drew stationary figures
with single contour lines.
These are easy to
render to a word cut.
And the body is presented
in an idealized classical
form and pose.
In contrast, Joyce
Cutler-Shaw uses repeated
and varied contour marks,
like we often see in
Leonardo drawings.
These ragged, uneven strokes
are in constant motion,
expressing fragile
forms referring
to modern vulnerabilities.
The intaglio method
of photographer well
complies to the style.
It may appear curious
that Ketham's vein man doesn't
really exhibit actual veins
and arteries.
Depiction of these
were difficult
and the capillary
system was not even known
yet in the 15th century,
it was first described
Marcello Malpighi in 1661.
Familiar with that knowledge,
the modern "Anatomy Lesson,"
conversely, delineates
the myriad of small veins
and arteries and other
anatomical intricacies
in much detail.
The following is from
Joyce Cutler-Shaw's poem
for the vein man
page, and I quote.
"Originally barber surgeons
were authorized to use the knife
for therapeutic bleeding,
as from waist
for purging melancholy."
So, let us see now how
bloodletting was supposed
to cure melancholy.
The presumed effect of
bloodletting was based
on the ancient humeral
theory, which claimed
that diseases were caused by
an imbalance of bodily humors
such as blood yellow bile,
black bile and phlegm.
The four humors were associated
with the four basic elements.
Air, fire, earth, and water.
And corresponded with four
qualities and four temperaments,
sanguine, choleric,
melancholic, and phlegmatic.
Another ancient medical
idea embodied
in humanoid form is the zodiac
man, or astrological man,
often depicted in medieval
and renaissance scientific
illustrations.
With the signs of the zodiac
on certain body parts,
the figure symbolized man's
relation to the cosmos.
In other words, the microcosm
and macrocosm theory.
Each body part is under the
influence of a constellation,
and the shifting patterns
of the heavens cause
changes in the body.
Thus, the circumstances of the
universe determine what can,
should, or should not be
done to the body in terms
of medical procedures
at certain times.
For example, when the moon
is in the sign of Aries,
it is not safe to touch
the head with iron
or use medications on it.
Joyce Cutler-Shaw's zodiac man
brings us into a new world.
Instead of Ketham's standing
figure with the signs
of the zodiac on
his athletic body,
here we see a skeletal cadaver
lying in the pose and angle
in extreme foreshortening.
Just like the famous
Mantegna tempura painting,
The Lamentation of Christ.
The body's covered
with a shroud.
So, what is the significance
of the shroud
for Joyce Cutler-Shaw?
It covers and obstructs
the body,
like the astrology-based
microcosm macrocosm theory
obstructed real anatomical
knowledge in ancient
and medieval medical theory
for several centuries.
Lifting the shroud, leads to
new anatomical understanding
to empirical science based
on observation and not only
on ancient written resources.
The third figure in our
comparison is the wound man.
He has numerous representations
in the late middle ages
and the renaissance, both
in manuscript and print.
This long-suffering character
can bravely bear all possible
wounds caused by all
possible weapons.
Maybe because treatment
is close,
written right around the figure.
The Ketham wound man
has much in common
with the manuscript counterpart.
Each has the same number of
weapons hitting the body.
The weapons are pictured
in the same position causing
the same kind of injury.
Yet, the artistic style
is very different.
The late medieval image
features a schematic rendition
of the human body in a
somewhat awkward pose.
Whereas the Ketham figure
radiates naturalistic
renaissance harmony.
I'm trying to start
a video here.
The modern version
of the wound man
in "The Anatomy Lesson"
draws our attention
from the wide array of
early weapons and wounds
to ultimate destruction.
In her dramatic image, Joyce
Cutler-Shaw concentrated
on human's ever escalating
skill to devise more
and more deadly weaponry
throughout history.
And especially in
the modern era.
Her illustration for this
topic commemorates the tragedy
of the victims of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
She conducted thorough
research for these pages,
which extended not only
to scrutinizing rare books
but also visiting
military museums.
The last Ketham illustration
in our comparison is
titled traditionally,
The Anatomy Lesson, and
depicts dissection scene.
It was not yet present in the
1491 first edition but appeared
as a new image in 1493,
when Mondino de Luzzi's anatomy
text was also newly added
to the volume.
The appearance of this image,
and the new text marks a
transformational moment.
It represents that what we
described as the lifting
of the shroud by
Joyce Cutler-Shaw,
mainly the beginning of
observational anatomy.
The central figure
here is the surgeon,
who exemplifies specific
practical
and professional competence
at the moment more important
than the academic rank
of the professor sitting
in the background.
It is also notable that
the other central figure
in this illustration
is the student.
This is Joyce Cutler-Shaw's
"Anatomy Lesson" illustration.
She writes in her poem, "Anatomy
by authority from a book,
as a professor reads from
his cathedra, as physician
and obeisance students stand
below to watch a barber surgeon
of the lowest rank to
perform the cuts until dazzled
by computerized cadavers,
3D artists spin their magic
for students at their screens.
And finally, the volume of
"The Anatomy Lesson" has an
intricate stitched concertina
binding, which was co-defined
by Joyce Cutler-Shaw
and Daniel Kelm.
The brown paper on the spine
is a continuous sheet folded
in accordion style to
create narrow tabs.
Between two tabs stitching
fastens each gathering
to three white linen bands
going across the spine.
On the front cover,
a holographic image shows an
18th-century lancet in 3D.
The book then fits in
an elegant metal box.
Ketham's volume is
called a herald
in the development of science.
And it marks the dawn
of empirical anatomy.
It is also considered one of
the most beautiful books made
in the first century
of printing.
Joyce Cutler-Shaw's modern
rendition is not only an equally
beautiful reworking
of the Ketham book,
but also thought-provoking new
creation through its own merit.
She thus, summarizes
her artistic intents.
I am interested in
new iconography
without losing a sense
of the physical self.
More and more in media, we
are fragmented, time-eclipsed,
dissolved and scale shifted.
We read ourselves
miniature on screens.
I want to have a
contemporary language
that addresses this
kind of fragmentation.
And I also want to
put it in the context
that makes us aware
of the whole.
I think Joyce Cutler-Shaw has
wonderfully achieved these goals
in her book, which was
inspired by the age-old Ketham.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Katherine Blood:
Good morning.
I'm Katherine Blood, the
library's curator of fine print
in the Princeton
Photographs Division,
where I have the opportunity
to work with everything
from etchings by
Rembrandt and Mary Cassatt
to born digital artists
protest posters from the Library
of Congress collections.
Here, on the second day
of our symposium exploring
scientific illustration
and intersections between art
and science it is my pleasure
to introduce artist and
neuroscientist, Dr. Greg Dunn.
Dunn, who received his PhD in
neuroscience from the University
of Pennsylvania in 2011, has
devoted his career to the fusion
of art, neuroscience
and engineering
to explore the mystery
and beauty of the mind.
Working with fellow artists
and applied physicist,
Dr. Brian Edwards, Dunn has
created an extraordinary
mind-bending and extraordinarily
beautiful artwork called
Self-Reflected, which we will be
hearing about in detail shortly.
Dr. Dunn's larger body of work
also reflects his admiration
of Asian art and
aesthetic connections
between neuro features and
tree-like branching forms
that suggests Sumi ink
scroll and screen paintings
from Japan's Edo period.
Other artworks carry titles
like Cortical Columns,
Neuro Migration, and my personal
favorite, Brainbow Hippocampus.
In exploring Dunn's work, I
started seeing connections
with aspects of artworks
I've had the opportunity
to spend quality time with,
with my own personal
bias and interests.
Including artist responses to
issues of the body and health
and the environment for example.
I thought of Eric Avery.
An artist, printmaker and
longtime practicing physician,
known for his artworks
responding to the AIDS epidemic
and related to other infectious
diseases including performative
on-site testing for
diseases in artist settings.
I also thought of Sandy
Gellis and her Spring
in the Northern Hemisphere.
It's a series of abstract
images with marks made
by laying etching plates
exposing her etching plates
to rain and other
natural elements.
And of course, we could go on
and on and pause at a multitude
of kindred spirits from
different approaches.
But I came away feeling
that Dunn's work really also
fills utterly unto itself,
with wonder and deep
first-person knowledge
as key ingredients.
You can read media responses
to Self-Reflected in "Wired,"
"The Atlantic," and "The
Huffington Post" to name a few.
And when talking about the work
in a filmed PBS segment called
"Greg Dunn Thinking About
Thinking," Dunn explained
that the reflective
micro-etching technique
that he uses was always in
service to the idea of how
to show the brain in all
of its full complexity.
He has also placed his
impulse to depict the beautiful
in science and nature within the
larger art historical movement
of naturalism but using
modern technology toward
envoi naturalism.
Deeper still, Dr. Dunn
invites us into a shared state
of meta-awareness, in
considering his art,
saying in his words,
"Self-Reflected is designed
to reflect what is
occurring in our own minds
as we observe this work of art.
Reminding us all that the
most marvelous machine
in the new universe is
at the core of our being
and at the root of
our shared humanity."
Now, to guide us on this journey
please welcome Dr. Greg Dunn.
[ Applause ]
>> Greg Dunn: Thank you
very much Katherine.
Thank you to Mark and
Stephanie in the Library
of Congress for having me here.
And as excited as I am
to be here, I have to say
that the most exciting thing
for me right now is that unlike
in the dram that I had the other
night, I actually remembered
to put pants on this
morning [laughter].
So, I'm pleased that that.
So, I have a lot to say, so
I'm going to get started here.
And I want to talk a little bit
about the intersection
of art and science.
And what my definition of it is.
This is an oil painting,
incredibly.
And this, in my opinion
is a science experiment.
Why? If you had 100
sufficiently skilled artists,
the results of their
experiments would be identical
because they're referencing
external reality
to collect the data to be
able to make this work of art.
Which is exactly what you want
when you're doing
experiment in the lab.
Science is about describing
the external universe.
Whereas art if you want
to think about it in terms
of this spectrum, I think is
more about bringing something
out of our subjective
of experience
into objective reality for
others to be able to appreciate.
So, this Gerhard Richter
abstract piece might have been,
you're asking an artist paint
what frustration feels like.
And every single artist is going
to paint something a
little bit different.
Because it's not something
that we can really reference
through external reality.
And almost every single thing
that we do all the time is
some blend of those two things.
Like this Craig Mullin's piece,
where he clearly understands the
rules of how the universe works;
perspective and the
reflectivity,
and this sort of thing.
But brings us to a place
which doesn't actually exist.
And I think that this is
the most fertile territory
for both art and science.
And scientists, I think are
constantly intuitively turning
inward in order to
gain inspiration
for their experiments as well.
So, how does this
kind of translate
into scientific imagery?
Well, this is a photomicrograph.
If you're infusing fluorescent
proteins into a section
of tissue, this is pretty much
as verbatim as you're going
to get in terms of being able
to analyze the anatomy here.
Whereas this would be the
other side of that spectrum.
A representation
of the brain done
in watercolors by
Holly Warren here.
But I'm going to go here and a
little bit out on a limb and say
that Santiago Ramon y Cajal
who is widely recognized
as the godfather of
modern neuroscience.
He won the Nobel Prize in
1906 for Spain for some
of his work kind of
elucidating the world of neurons
in the neural circuitry.
As you can see here on the
right that you have some
of his slides immediately
juxtaposed
with his illustration
of the slides.
And at this time, a lot
of researchers were using a
technique called camera lucida.
Which is a technique
that enables you
to sort project the image of
a microscope onto a surface
so that you could
trace it more or less.
And Cajal used this
only sparingly.
And what I don't think is really
appreciated as much these days,
and it's a little bit of a
difficult comparison to make
because imaging technology
is so vastly superior
to what it was in Cajal's time.
But when you're looking at a
slide, it's one very small slice
of a much more complex system
that you're looking at.
These neurons are snaking
around in three dimensions
you're looking
at a lot of different slides.
You're bringing in the
context of your other knowledge
about neuroscience in order
to interpret what's happening.
And Cajal, I think,
rightly recognized
that making an illustration
that caricaturing the circuit
was actually a more effective
way to communicate these
difficult points then was
showing a photograph, verbatim.
And when I think
about, you know,
what the average person thinks
about when they think
about their own mind.
The thing that is at the
most fundamental aspect
of who we are as people.
The sort of depressing answer is
that this is probably what
most people think about.
It is a translucent blue walnut
with lightning coming out of it.
As is sort of the
illustration meme de jure.
And this is another kind
of common one that you see.
You know, neurons floating
in space with a little bolt
of electricity traveling
between them.
Which is illustrating the
point that neurons communicate
through action potentials.
Which are indeed, darts
of electrical potential
which travel along their axon.
Which is the part that
communicates activity
to downstream neurons.
And that receives
these electrical inputs
through their dendrites,
which is their kind of branch
like structure that they use
to collect information from.
And they also kind of look
like those robot octopuses
from "The Matrix to me.
So, this is telling you a
little bit about the brain.
This is just a tiny fraction.
The brain has 86
billion of these things.
And that's only the neurons.
There's a lot of other
stuff going on as well.
So, in terms of being
able to elucidate
for the average person what it
is that were dealing with here,
I think these communicate
a very specific point,
but not a particularly
broad one.
And a lot of people are familiar
with the scientific
imagery here.
This is a functional
magnetic resonance image.
And this is telling you
while you're in the scanner,
what might be happening
in your brain
when you're picking your
nose, for example in this.
That's the brain area
that controls that.
And this is telling us that
the brain is compartmentalized
in terms of its activity.
And I suspect that these
types of images were also key
in communicating the incorrect
conclusion that we only use 10%
of our brains at any
really in totality.
Which is so utterly ridiculous
as to, it boggles the mind.
If the most energy hungry part
of our body was only using 10%
of its capacity, then
evolution would have evolved
that out instantaneously.
It is completely incorrect.
So, this is now more of the kind
of fluorescent scientific
imagery.
This is probably, some
of you may have seen
this type of thing.
And this is starting to
belie the true complexity
of the anatomy here.
Of course, this is not
telling us what it looks
like in three dimensions.
And typically, microscopy
is only able
to show us a little
bit at a time.
And it's not able to show us
how the brain evolves in time,
and what it looks like in time.
Which is really one of its
most incredible aspects.
And of course, we're
all familiar
with what the meat
of it looks like.
And I remember holding a
brain in graduate school
and being surprised
at how little you can actually
understand about it just
by holding the thing
in your hands.
It's like all the vein
diagrams as Lilla was talking
about earlier, pointing to
all the different regions.
It is very difficult
to tell what going on.
It's just this kind of peach
and lighter peach color,
kind of intermixed int his way.
So, I became kind of inspired
to represent the brain
in different qualities
and methods
when I was in graduate school.
And one of the reasons
is you're just exposed
to so many gorgeous pictures
of the brain all the time.
And I've always been a
fan of Asian art too,
which is part of this context.
This is one of my
favorite paintings, the red
and white plumb blossoms.
This is the from the
Edo period in Japan.
And this type aesthetic was also
happening in China and in Korea.
And one of the things
I love so much
about this art is
typically that it's sparse.
There's a lot of negative space.
And they tend to emphasize
the incredibly beautiful
and spontaneous branching
patterns
that you would find in nature.
One thing that's difficult to
paint, that's difficult to do
in this type of painting is
that your brain is not good
at generating randomness.
It tends to want to build
patterns out of things.
So, actually the Zen approach
is to paint and to try
to release your mind
from its instinct
to make those types of patterns.
But what I found when I was
looking at neurons all day is
that these branching
patterns are absolutely
in common with neurons.
And the reason is that nature
has encountered a similar
problem at different scales.
In the world of neurons, the
goal is to splay your dendrites
out in order to collect as
many synapses as possible,
whereas a tree, of course,
is trying to collect
as much light as possible.
A lightning bolt is trying
to discharge its electrical
potential down to the earth
and it finds the path
of least resistance.
That's essentially what
this shape is, it's the path
of least resistance,
which is controlled
by other detailed variables
depending upon the system.
What I didn't have,
unfortunately,
for the astronomers in the
audience, which there are a few,
is that the orientations
of galactic super clusters also
look like this neural shape.
This is a fractal.
And fractal is a common
shape which repeats
through different
orders of magnitude.
So, some of my initial
work, like this piece Basket
in Pyramidals which is you
know, a simple ink painting
on gold leaf, is as much
a declaration saying
that the world of neurons fits
very cleanly into the canon
of Asian art, but also that
the world is made of fractals.
Because somebody who doesn't
know about neuroscience,
might look at this and
say, oh this is trees.
But it's kind of not like trees.
What's going on here.
And to have somebody be in
that state of uncertainty
for a little while
is kind of the point.
That there's a comfortable kind
of presentation of the idea
that then stretches you
as you consider it a
little bit more deeply.
And to further this point home,
these are some of the scrolls
that I painted, and still
paint every once in a while.
This one on the left
is of the retina.
Here's one of after sights, and
one of the emerging complexity
and kind of opaqueness of
complexity in the brain.
And this is to further
drive that point home
between the connection
of these two worlds.
I began to experiment with
reflectivity in my art
as something akin to form and
color in order to emphasize.
You can draw the viewer's
eye to specific things
when you're using reflectivity.
And it's not something that
has been very deeply explored
in the history of art.
And so, unfortunately, I don't
have a video of this piece,
but when you move around
it, those white stripes
or these lighter stripes
right here would actually move
depending upon where
the light is.
My sister kind of describes
this as looking like the scales
of a trout is the idea.
And it puts things into
and out of silhouette.
Here's a piece of
the spinal cord.
And Pedro was saying yesterday,
which I thought was a really
good point is that it's nice
to be able to give
somebody familiar context
when you're describing
something is unfamiliar to them.
And so, this piece I
kind of stylized to look
like the blue iridescence
of a morph of butterfly
as the anatomy of the structure
is definitely reminiscent
as such.
Katherine mentioned, I'm
really interested in the idea
that your brain has evolved
to investigate itself.
What a weird concept that is.
And this piece is really
exploring that idea.
that this is a multi-electrode
chip.
So, right now in neuroscience
at the forefront you stick
these electrodes in the brain
and are reading the
brain activity
of this neural network here
and you're reading essentially,
these electric pulses which
are going between the neurons.
And this piece is
style is to look
like almost an alien
abduction to call you know,
the point being that there is
the sort of strange relationship
to the brain wanting
to understand itself.
This piece is called
Axon Pathfinding,
and it's about chaos that
emerges when you have many,
many axons growing towards their
locations at a similar time
and make chaotic patterns
which emerge from that process.
This piece is called
Hippocampal Formations.
The hippocampus is
a part of the brain
that controls learning
and memory.
And this is equally inspired
by the hippocampus itself
and by the erosion patterns
in the desert in Jordan.
I was looking at some
satellite imagery
and sure enough rain hitting
mountains and then shedding off
into the rivers down below is
also major solution in a path
of least resistance that
really resembles this type
of neural form.
So, this is kind of a hybrid,
and again is commenting
on that fractal nature
of the universe.
And I do occasionally do things
which are not related
to the brain.
This is a recent piece called
Photosynthesis which is about,
a simulation of how nutrients
and water would be transported
in the vasculature of leaves.
But this this next
piece, Self-Reflected,
is I think a categorical
difference
in how I had been
illustrating the brain
and painting up to this point.
And it emerged from an
existential frustration
that I felt in graduate school.
Where you're working
on a project that's
pretty complicated.
You make a breakthrough
on it and you feel
like you finally understand
something about the brain.
And Lester Hubris,
take you to a place
where you really shouldn't be.
And lest your hubris
take you to a place
where you really shouldn't
be, it's always a good idea
to be searching the
literature and find
out what other people
are thinking about that.
Which point you find 600 papers
that you had never considered
and then you consider that the
amount that people actually know
about the brain is a fraction
of what is actually going on.
So, to be able to communicate
the incredible awe and beauty
that I saw in the brain.
I wanted to invent a technique
that would be able to kind
of communicate that emotionally
and perceptually to people.
So, what you're about to see
is a reflective micro-etching
and this is the world's
most complex depiction
of the human brain.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] This
is what's happening
in your brain at this moment.
This is not a digital
piece of art.
This is a physical
object hanging on the wall
which is being illuminated
from overhead
by various light sources.
This is the collective
simulated activity
of half a million
neurons at once.
And this object is made
of millions and millions
of tiny etches that
are microscopic
in the surface of
this gold plate.
The color that you're seeing
is not inherent to the piece,
the color comes from the fact
that there are these different
colors of light source which are
above the piece and are
reflecting off of the service.
So, really the aesthetic
innovation
of reflective micro-etching is
the color has now been turned
into an infinite variable.
This is a demonstration of when
you're passing kind of a sheet
across the various lamps
that are over the piece,
and you can see that each one
of those colors has essential,
a channel of reflectivity,
which it's optimized towards.
[ Music ]
So, this shot now is really the
meat of what the project is.
This is what it is
in animation mode
when the light is
draping over the surface.
And you'll see in the lower
left-hand corner here coming
up that this is where we
are zoomed into the piece.
And right now, we're
in the cerebral cortex,
which is that walnut shaped
covering of the brain.
This right here is
the parietal cortex.
Where you're integrating your
vision and your movements.
So, you're reaching
out to pet a cat
or to punch somebody
in the face.
This is the somatosensory
cortex.
This is where you
would feel sensations
on your skin, for example.
Right now, coming into the
motor cortex, this contains some
of the largest neurons
in the body.
And these are the types of
calculations that are being made
when you're playing
piano for example.
And you're learning, and you're
refining these circuits in order
to optimize what it is that
you're doing with your brain.
And you can see how the neurons
are arranged in these kind
of laminar type structures.
Particularly, in the
rear part of the brain
where they communicate both
vertically and horizontally
to integrate information.
And as we continue here
into the frontal cortex.
So, we're about right
here right now.
Right behind the forehead.
You'll notice that the activity
becomes more chaotic here.
There's a lot more
interneurons which help
to refine the local circuitry.
This is the part of the brain
which is controlling
logic and planning.
And this is what differentiates
us from the higher primates.
This region of the
brain spins on its own,
even without any sensory input.
This is what thinking
looks like.
And these neurons are sending
their information down,
back into the central
brain structures which tend
to be the more evolutionarily
distant types
of very basic emotional
movement type centers.
And now we're getting
into the basal forebrain
where you have a lot of
the structures involved
in motivation and reward.
That big burst that
you'll see at the bottom
of your screen right
there, is what it might look
like when something pleasurable
and unexpected happens,
or like snorting a line
of cocaine would be the
activation of that region.
We're now in the
basal ganglia here.
The caudate nucleus.
This is where you integrate your
kind of logical perceptions.
Your emotions, your memories,
your sensory perceptions
in order to plan your movements.
And now, we're in the
thalamus which is the very,
very center of the brain.
And there is so much
stuff happening here.
So many things being
routed in and out.
And the way in which this is
region gates information allows
us to pay attention to
things more or less.
There's a lot of important
regions involved in attention
and arousal, and these large
tracks coming down here,
which are coming from the
motor cortex will become the
spinal cord.
And are executing the movements
that you are planning kind
of in your higher
order cerebral.
A lot of these structures here
in the brainstem are
very basic to life.
Like breathing and hunger.
And now we're getting into the
cerebellum, which is right here
at the very back of your
brain, which is kind
of a brain in and of itself.
This involves movement
and proprioception,
which is how you sense
your body in space.
And this region by
itself contains half
of the neurons in your brain.
There are 50 billion
neurons in this region.
Coming back up, now
the spinal cord
and we see the colliculi here
this is for auditory information
and for visual information,
respectively.
And then we're coming into,
back around to where we started.
This is the lateral geniculate
nucleus of the thalamus
which is receiving information
from the optic nerve,
from the eyes.
Which is sending
information here
to the primary visual cortex,
where these neurons are
calculating very simple things
about your visual system,
like where all the
angles are for example.
And that gets passed up into
higher order visual cortex here.
So, that is what
Self-Reflective looks like.
And of course, I want
to credit my good buddy
and collaborator Brian,
who also worked tirelessly
on this project.
So, what is a micro-etching?
So, I mentioned again
previously,
that a micro-etching is
millions of tiny little etches
in the surface of
a metallic surface.
This is a very, very close up
photo of what that looks like.
You can see that whatever
is a specific color is made
up of etches of a
specific angle.
So, the blue is at a different
angle than the red is.
But again, the color is not
inherent in the surface.
Nor does the color from light
splitting off of the surface
like you seen a hologram.
It's due to the fact that the
lamps are different colors.
And that the consequent of
that is that when you move
around this those colors
are going to be shifting,
which is how we are able to
engineer the lighting in this.
And this is what that
the surface looks
like under scanning
electron microscope.
This is a 1200 x
image on showing you
that we have these
wavelike reflectors.
And this kind of doesn't
look like anything here.
But the business end of
this is so abstract compared
to what the macroscopic
perspective of it is.
And just quickly, I
wanted to show you this.
So, this is really
the primary data,
which goes into the
creation of this piece.
Just look at this little
structure right here that's
going out here, this
little dendrite.
You can see that the
angle changes gradually
as you move across the surface.
When a light moves over that
surface, the consequence
of that is that you're going
to get this angle is going
to be optimal to where the light
is at a very specific point.
So, you'll see a bright
spot originate here,
and then travel along
the structure,
which is how we're able
to achieve those animated
effects using this technique.
And around this time,
and I'm forever grateful
to the National Science
Foundation for believing in us
to give us this grant
to fund this project.
Because we're essentially
funding a visualization.
And the thing we told them is,
look, we're in the golden age
of neuroscience right now.
I consider it of great
philosophical importance
that people have a more
enriched understanding
of what their brain is.
And the goal of this
project is to change the way
in which the average person
thinks about their brains.
And they indeed rewarded
us with the grant.
And we were very
grateful for that.
So, one of the first
things that we had
to decide is what
we're going to show.
And we decided to show
a sagittal section,
oblique sagittal, so it's coming
through your head like this.
Because there's a lot of
really interesting structures.
You can show things to their
completion and it seemed
like a good region to begin.
And this is a representation of
the best data that was available
at the time for the human brain.
Compared with the
resolution that we were trying
to work with, this was
woefully inadequate.
So, this piece would not scan.
It's so far from that.
It was made entirely
from scratch.
And I'll tell you more
about how that was done.
And one of the things I
really want to emphasize too,
is that there was a lot of
kind of balancing the art
and the science in this piece.
You know, what are the things
that are crucial to be able
to show verbatim and
what are the things
which could be bent
a little bit in order
to make a point more strongly.
And one of the things that
was really nice actually
in some ways at least, is
that the state of the data
in the human brain is so poor
compared to what it would be
in mice, or rats, or even like
a rhesus monkey that we just had
to fill it in you know, with our
best guess in a lot of cases.
So, this is a map of where all
the gray matter regions are.
Gray matter is where
the cell bodies are.
So, each color here is
indicating a different
functional region.
This is a rough map.
It's more complicated than this.
But with the help of some
of our neuroscience students
at the University Pennsylvania,
we went through each
of these regions and just
did a ton of research
in the primary literature as
to what the neurons look like,
what they're connected to,
what their firing patters
are like, blah, blah, blah.
So that we could
get this accurate.
And as there were no
really good pictures
for what all the neurons look
like, and because I wanted
to infuse more of an artistic
sort of flare to this.
Almost an abstract
expressionism,
using the technique
I'm about to show you,
we decided to paint all
the neurons by hand.
[Background Music] So, this
technique was invented to get
over the fact that your
brain again is terrible
at generating randomness.
When you try to paint neurons
with your hand, you're going
to put a node every 2
centimeters and you're going
to find that rule, and you're
going to undo it and then some
of the rule is going to emerge.
With this technique,
you're allowing nature
to make fractals, just
like it wants to do.
You have loose control over it,
but the turbulence of the error
and the inconsistency
of the fiber direction
of the paper is going to cause
that ink droplet to split
up into these beautiful
fractal -like patterns,
which are highly reminiscent
of neurons to begin with.
So, we painted about 150
different categories of neurons
and a few examples of each,
scanned them into the computer
and turned them into vector
objects, which we then used
to paint the gray matter down.
We painted down about a million
neurons using this technique.
So, that's how the
gray matter was made.
But the white matter is
in this image right here,
whatever is black stained
in that image is what
the white matters.
The white matter
are the collections
of axons traveling long
distances, carrying information
between the different
brain regions.
And what's impossible
to see in this image is
that this is incredible very,
very beautiful structure,
very complicated of
many highways kind
of traversing one another.
And so, we had to send
our friend Dr. John Pyles
into the future with this time
machine to bring this image back
to us via diffusion
spectrum imaging.
This is a render of a magnetic
technique that's similar to MRI.
And we filtered this dataset to
be in the plane of our dataset
that we're interested in here.
And this became then, the
inspiration to paint all
of the vector shapes of
the axons by hand as well.
So, this was done mostly
in Adobe Illustrator.
And this is an example
of two of these sets.
These are cortical sheets that
we used to input into the piece.
So now we have a lot of neurons
and we have a lot of axons.
But there is no connection,
nor causality sort
of between these circuits.
And as complex as
it was already,
this has already
taken over a year.
This next part is really what
brought the piece to life
and infused the third
dimension into it.
Because micro-etchings
essentially allow you through,
through reflectivity to impart
a third dimension into the art.
And in this case, it's time.
So, you have a neuron, it
fires an action potential,
it travels down its axon.
You have a group of
neurons that's communicating
with a downstream group of
neurons, via their axons.
So, this is one step of
choreography as we called it.
One set of neurons communicating
with the next downstream
set of neurons.
And this is what my
artist palette looked
like at some point.
So, less you think that
as an artist I was walking
into my studio and flinging
my cape off and saying,
well what am I going
to create today.
I sat down in front of this
damn computer and just,
it was basically
coding at some point.
There's about 30 variables
controlling the speed
of the impulses, whether or
not the neurons are firings
as a group or individually,
etcetera.
And there's about
there's about 600 lines
of this choreography here.
So, this is much more like
taking some artsy fartsy hippies
and forcing them to do the
most brutal corporate taxes
[laughter] that have existed.
So, this is definitely a bridge
between art and engineering
here.
I don't have a whole lot
of time to go into this.
But what I wanted to say
with this slide is again
we're dealing with time here.
So, when we're programming
a circuit, neuron a is going
to fire at time equals 0.
Neuron b is going to fire
at time equals some
time later than that.
And when we're working with
two-dimensional images,
the way that we encode that
time is through hue space.
Through these different colors.
So, neurons which
are firing early
in the animation
will be a red color.
Then you'll see the orange
neurons, then the yellow ones,
then the green ones,
blue ones, etcetera.
So, as the light moves
over it, you're not going
to see these colors
in the final piece.
You're going to see the
neurons which are red
in the computer data
as being illuminated
when you're standing all the
way to the left of the piece.
And then if you were to walk
from one side to the other,
you'd see the orange ones,
yellow ones etcetera.
So, this is a close up of
what this render looks like.
And this is what the whole
brain looks like after,
I don't even remember
it was days' worth
of crunch time for
this algorithm.
To give you a sense of what
the complexity of the math is
like here, it's similar to a
logistics company's solving,
we need to deliver 100
packages and we need
to find the optimal
route to do it.
Which is a notoriously
challenging math problem.
There's a lot of different
variables at play there.
And we're doing this for
half a million neurons.
So, that took a good long time.
And then the question
is how do we turn this
into a physical object, right?
Because we now have this
data in the computer,
but we need to turn it into
the physical micro-etching.
We have the data plotted
out into two dimensions,
and we have this third
dimension of color in the piece.
So, the thing that
you must know.
The very first thing
you need to know is
where the light source
is going to be.
And let's just choose
any pixel randomly
on the surface micro-etching.
We know based on that pixel's
color where we want the observer
to be able to see it from.
So, we know then what the
position of the viewer is,
and we know the angle
that we need the light
to come off of that surface at.
Knowing these two angles, now,
this angle to light source,
this angle to the observer.
We can now extrapolate
the angle at which we need
to make a little tiny
mirror at that spot.
And rather than make
bevels like in a diamond,
which would be reflecting a ray
of light to very specific point.
We're actually making
little cylinders
which splay the light out more.
So, that if you're
short or if you're tall,
you can see the reflections
coming off of it.
And we're actually, for each
pixel making a little grid
of these cylindrical reflectors.
So, the rendering
at the end of this,
is we've increased the
resolution by factor of 10,
And this is what it looks
like in great detail here.
So, you can see the
outline of a neuron here.
Which is made of one
specific angle of hatching.
Those are printed
onto transparencies
at ultrahigh resolution.
You would never be able to
see that with your naked eye.
The feature size in this is
about 100 microns which is
about as big as an
average human hair.
Then we used those
transparencies
to do photolithography.
This is how computer
chips are manufactured,
and how etched plates have
been made in the past as well.
So, you start with
a sheet of steel.
We laminate a photoresist,
which is an ultraviolet
light-sensitive polymer
on top of that.
And then we put our
transparency on top of that.
So, of course, in the
transparency you have regions
which are printed and
regions which are clear.
When you turn on the UV
light, the light penetrates
through the clear
region and polymerize,
makes that part directly
under here hard.
Everything else underneath the
black printing is protected
by that black printing,
it remains soft.
So, turn off the UV light,
remove the transparency,
dip the whole place
into a basic solution.
And it eats away anything
that was underneath
those black lines.
And we can do this in
very, very high resolution.
So, you're using light, and
chemicals, and transparencies
to essentially burn this
image into three dimensions.
Here's some images of
laminating the materials.
This is in the clean
room in the studio.
This is the UV light
source right here.
Here's the plate being
exposed on the wall.
And so, now this is what the
photo-resist surface looks like.
That's where the etching
is actually done in,
it's this dark purple,
which is reflective,
but not super reflective.
And because this art is
completely based upon
reflectivity, we need to
brighten it up a little bit.
And we learn that gold leaf
is the perfect solution
to this problem.
Because gold leaf is super
thin, it's 200 nanometers thick.
So, it's so much thinner than
our relevant feature size
that it's not going
to fill in all
of our topography and wreck it.
It's malleable enough
that you can force it
into all those tiny
little crevasses.
It's never going to tarnish,
and it looks awesome.
And everybody likes gold.
So, it was the perfect
engineering
and aesthetic solution
to this problem.
This is the initial kind
of lining up of the plates,
which then needed to be
cut down in the final step,
and here's Brian here, when
we developed this method
to cut these plates to
within about 100th of an inch
of one another, so that they
would line up seamlessly.
And this is an assembly of nine
of those plates on the floor
of my studio on the first
day that we assembled.
And Brain stressing out
about some tiny little detail
that nobody would ever see.
We built a light source for
the piece where it's installed
at the Franklin Institute
in Philadelphia,
so that we could get
all these effects.
These are some of the
students that worked
on it with us, and us.
This kind of looks like
the Ghost Busters' car now
that I look at it
better right here.
And this is what the
image looks like just
under a single white light.
But again, a micro-etching
has so much flexibility
in how it's viewed that this is
only a fraction of the amount
of data which is really in it.
You can put different
colors of light around it.
This image just won the National
Science Foundation's Science
Engineering Contest last year.
And it's surrounded by three
or four different lights.
And here's just some other
quick, kind of close-ups
of what the image, or
the piece looks like
and that color is
kind of cool here too
because color is
indicating what is firing
at that particular moment.
So, all the red neurons in
this image would be firing
at the same time.
So, there is data encoded into
the colors of these images.
And this is what it looks
like in situ in the museum.
And I can guarantee you
that there were many times
during the production
of this piece, for the three
years of my life it took
to make this thing, the hardest
thing I'd ever worked on,
where I was asking myself,
why am I doing this?
You know, like what really
is going to come of this.
And the thing that really kept
me going was imagining a kid
going into this museum
and standing in front
of this gigantic gold
glittering object.
And have the light strafe over
the piece for the first time.
And the kid to look up
at it and just say, wow.
And then for them to jump
up and down and run off
to the next thing and mash
buttons somewhere else
in the museum, or
for them not to.
Or for them to look
at it more deeply.
But, you know what.
I don't care if people
look at this piece
and they don't remember
that the thalamus
and the cortex have
recurrent connections.
Or they don't understand
where the cerebellum is.
I don't care about any of that.
All that's there if
you're looking for it.
The thing that's most
important about this piece is
that it makes that initial
emotional impact we learn
through our emotions.
It's the most important
thing we can do
to communicate effectively
with people.
Excuse me, and to that end,
one of the most important parts
that I learned in grad
school was this idea that,
so the visual system is
ridiculously complex.
I mean we're very
visual creatures.
We navigate the world with it.
And we use vision to
keep us safe, right?
We need to be constantly
analyzing our environment
and make sure we don't get
bitten by a snake for example.
And milliseconds here.
So, when light hits your retina,
it goes to the optic nerve
through the thalamus and into
the primary visual cortex,
where you have you're
processing again.
Things like basic angles.
You're combining those
into form, you're looking
at whether motion is happening,
you're looking at color.
And these are higher
order structures
where the information
gets passed to.
But this is being processed
largely in parallel,
which is a more efficient
processing technique.
If you were to process
it in series
where each step is contingent
on the data being complete
from the previous one, it would
take a lot longer to do this.
So, you need more machinery
to process in parallel,
but you can do it faster.
Basic form and silhouette
information is being siphoned
off of this pathway and is being
sent to your limbic system.
Which is basically
your emotional systems,
the amygdala right here.
This is before you're seeing it.
This is way subliminal.
You're not actually
consciously aware
of what's happening
at this point.
It's being processed through the
amygdala for emotional valance.
It's making sure that
there's nothing happening
in your visual field,
which is a threat.
Because if there is,
you want that data
to be there as fast as possible.
Which is why you get it there
in as early a state as possible.
Then that data is sent back
into your visual system
and is combined with the
rest of what's happening
in your visual system to
actually make this world
that we're seeing
on a daily basis.
But the implication of this is
that you are not
seeing verbatim reality.
You're seeing what your
emotions are coloring for you.
And I'm sure many of
you can understand
that the implications
of this are extreme.
And we don't have time to talk
about the societal
implications of this.
But in the context of
art, what's important is
that your silhouette
has got to be strong.
Because it's being analyzed
for emotional character before
anything else is even happening.
Illustration and making fine
art can really teach you a lot
about what your subject
material is too.
And I learned some interesting
kind of meta-realizations
from essentially
building a brain.
This one in particular,
normally people think
about brain development as
taking place with genetic
and epigenetic components.
So, genetics, of course, are the
genes we get from our parents,
our hardwired DNA sequences.
Which control who we are.
Which control how neurons grow
and find their destinations.
And then you have epigenetics.
Epi meaning outside of genetics.
This is how our environment
controls the expression
of our genes.
It's basically the software
of how we are functioning.
So, you could have a gene
which is folded up in its DNA,
in such a way the
machinery can't access it.
So, the genes can be turned on
and off via these
epigenetic mechanisms.
So, via these two
mechanisms you have billions
of axons growing towards their
targets in early development.
Try to imagine what it's like at
a place like St. Mark's Square
in Venice, where you have many
inputs into this huge plaza
which is just packed
with tourists constantly.
And they're all trying
to get somewhere.
And they're all bumping
into one another,
and they're all generally
getting to where they're going
with a large amount of chaos
happening at the same time.
This is what's happening in
early development as well.
Such that, if you had
even an identical brain,
in an identical environment
that the randomness involved
in this process, particularly
you're talking about billions
of objects moving against
one another at the same time,
means that the brain is going to
develop differently every time.
At this resolution
you're looking at it,
you might not be able
to see a difference.
But the devil is definitely
in the details here.
Where an axon might arrive
a little bit off target.
And if any of you have built
complicated things in your life,
you know that as you approach
perfection, once you get
that last 1% of details,
that last .01% of details,
or even more detail than
that, the ability to reach
that perfection becomes fleeting
and basically impossible.
And in particular
when you're working
with a system this complex.
The brain knows this, and
it is compensating for it.
The brain over connects
early in development.
It's at its maximum potential
This is why your damn
kid can learn words
in a foreign language
way faster than you can.
Because their brain is much
more plastic it has way
more potential.
Then, the brain perfects itself
depending upon what input you
give it.
So, in early life you know,
if you're reading a lot,
if you're playing outside
a lot, if you're you know,
learning a new language,
something like this,
it prunes away the irrelevant
connections and leaves you
with a much more kind
of refined template
than you would have
had otherwise.
And now, I guess kind of in sum,
just talking about what I try
to make my illustrations
to be and what I think
that Eleanor really
did very well yesterday
in some of her pieces.
Particular her Mars map,
I thought it really encompassed
a lot of these very well.
Is what components you need
in a truly effective image
that can change people's
perceptions.
I mean obviously the scientific
content has got to be there.
And it's got to be right
and it's got to be clear.
Having it be emotionally
engaging is also extremely
important because people
have got to care about it.
There's way too many
things to learn
about in our world right now.
We're consuming more data
at this moment than we have
in history by orders
of magnitude.
So, your thing had
better be interesting
and emotionally engaging.
Adding your own kind
of aesthetic and style
to it can also help to
differentiate it a little bit.
And one that I, like a practice
that I use too is to use what's
out there as almost a
negative inspiration in a way.
To use it as a constraint to
further refine my thinking away
from what currently
exists in the world.
Because there are a lot
of terrible ideas in here.
And one of the reasons I
become better as an artist is
because I've been better at
figuring out what is a good idea
and what isn't a good idea.
What do you want to
spend your time on?
I mean I don't think that
it's a measure of success
to relentlessly throw yourself
at a problem until you solve it.
It's much wiser to figure out
if a problem has potential early
on so that you can prune
it off and save your time,
other than waste your life.
So, when all these things are
there, and like I said with some
of Eleanor's pieces yesterday,
this was me at the center
of the Venn diagram [laughter].
Because that's how
the world moves ahead.
The humble scientific goal
of Self-Reflected was to blow
as many minds as possible.
That was that what we
were really going for.
So, if you want to
read more about,
there's a bunch articles
about this.
This is some of the place that
my work is hanging as well.
And I wanted to thank
sincerely, Mark, and Stephanie,
and everybody at the
Library of Congress
for giving me the
opportunity to speak here.
And all the scientists,
and artists and physicians
who contributed their knowledge
and expertise to this project,
as well as the students,
of course.
And that's, in the long-term
goal of this project again is
to transform the way in which
the average person thinks
about the brain.
So, some of the next steps
are in getting these pieces
into museums around the world.
And not just science museums.
I want to get them in
contemporary art museums.
Because I think that it would,
this term, neo-naturalism is one
that I'm trying to throw
around a little bit.
About this is a step forward in
the sense that I want to be able
to show things that the
average person just can't see
with their naked eyes.
I mean we, as scientists,
are incredibly privileged
that we get to use these
sophisticated tools
to see what many can't.
And I think bringing that
to the public's imagination
and inattention is
an important goal.
So, I'll be around afterwards
if you guys want to chat.
I have a sample of
a micro-etching
to show you if you're
interested.
And thank you so
much for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Shelby Callway: All right.
Morning everyone.
My name is Shelby
Callway, I'm the historian
at the US Department
of Agriculture's Natural
Resources Conservation Service.
And I'm delighted to be here
at this wonderful symposium.
And to get to introduce you all
to our next speaker,
Dr. Catherine Newell.
Professor Newell holds a
PhD from UC Santa Barbara,
and currently serves as a
professor of religious studies
at University of
Miami in Florida.
She has far too many honors for
me to list them all right now,
but just one that seems
especially relevant,
she's also the 2017/18
Larson Fellow in Health
and Spirituality
here at the Library
of Congress' John W.
Kluge Center for the Book.
Dr. Newell is an
outstanding scholar
of both the phenomenology
of religion
and the history of science.
Her research focuses on
the conjoined histories
of religion and science.
Particularly, the way in which
scientific paradigms frequently
owe their genesis to a
religious idea or belief.
Her forthcoming book,
which intersects
with several areas
we've discussed
at the symposium is tentatively
titled "The Wheels of Titan:
Faith, the Future and
the Final Frontier."
The book traces post-World
War II American zeal
for space exploration back
to 19th century religious
discourse surrounding belief
in American manifest destiny.
The volume focuses on
the artists, historians,
and scientists who
popularized space expiration
by framing the conquest
of the final frontier
as a modern religio-cultural
legacy
of the conquest of
the American west.
I'm sure you're all going to
want to rush out and buy it
as soon as it becomes available
after you hear this talk.
So, please join me in welcoming
Professor Catherine Newell.
[ Applause ]
>> Catherine Newell:
Good morning.
Thank you for that.
And thank you for
having me here today.
And I would say especially
thank you to Stephanie.
She told me about this symposium
I think it was this summer.
And I said I want to come, and
she said, you want to present.
So, here I am.
It's very exciting.
So, what I want to talk about
today is a little bit having
to do with again my
forthcoming volume,
and in particular the question
of where we got the idea
that space is the
final frontier.
So, it's not something
that maybe would occur
to us naturally to look at say
the surface of Mars, and say,
let's go there and explore,
on you maybe, not me.
But, I think for a long
time we've had a narrative
that this comes from
science fiction.
The most famous split
infinitive in TV history,
'seek out new life and new
civilizations and boldly go
where no one has gone before.'
And that's at least
partially true.
I found this letter to Willy
Ley, one of the people I'm going
to talk about today, in the
archives of the National Air
and Space Museum being
thanked by Gene Roddenberry,
himself inviting him
to come visit the set
of his very successful
television show, saying,
'we're looking forward to
meeting one of the pioneers
who made a space travel
television show possible.'
So, again these intersections
of science, arts,
culture, popular culture.
But Gene Roddenberry
did not invent the idea
of space as a frontier.
And in fact to understand more
about why we think of space
as our frontier, it's useful
to look back to images
that we're actually
surrounded by all
over here in Washington DC.
We're going to see
a lot of them today.
And this is actually one of the
later images I will talk about.
It was I think it even just
started life as a lithograph
in 1872 and it was
meant to illustrate
and it's very problematic.
And I know that we have people
fleeing before the power
of the image of Columbia,
heading west
from the east bringing with
her technology, like railroads,
and telegraph wires,
and chasing all
of the scary people
out of the way.
But it's useful as
a representation
of this concept of
manifest destiny.
Because even though we associate
manifest destiny with this kind
of conquest of the west,
it's also alive and well in
and around, particularly
the history of space
and most particularly
for my purposes,
what the people I called
the space proselytizers.
That even proceeded
to the American space
program were revitalizing
with their work and their art.
So, today we're going
to be talking
about these two gentlemen.
On the left, we have Chesley
Bonestell, actually sitting
in front of his background
for the film
"Destination Moon"
that he designed.
And next to him is Willy Ley.
Bonestell was an
architectural designer,
he became a movie
special effects artist.
We'll talk more about that.
And Ley actually started
his career in Germany
as a rocker expert
and science reporter.
And together they are more
than the sum of their parts.
I believe they created one
of the most influential books
on space exploration,
possibly ever written.
It was written for lay
audiences, published in 1949.
And build as a preview
of the greatest good venture
awaiting mankind with texts
and pictures based on the
latest scientific research.
And we'll get more into it.
but Ley and Bonestell wanted
to introduce the possibility
of the exploration of space,
but the idea of exploring space
in 1949 was so implausible
to the average person
who maybe wasn't engaged in
science fiction, that the two
of them had to connect
space exploration
to its more terrestrial cousin.
The historical conquest of
the American west we saw
in that John Gast painting.
So, the idea of exploration, and
the eventual settlement related
to the exploration of
outer space in general,
and for the purposes
of this book,
our solar system in particular.
So, what was at stake in
their idea of conquest
of space wasn't homestead
and settlements,
but actually the acts
of exploration itself.
So, I'm a scholar of religion
and we love having ideas
to frame what we do so we can
point at them and say, well,
I'm saying it, they're
saying it.
So, the person I
am using to kind
of frame this conversation
today is Edmundo O'Gorman
in his 1961 book, "The
Invention of America."
He said that the old notion
that imprisoned the world
within the bounds of an island
had been overcome with this kind
of so-called discovery
of the new world.
That essentially, it wasn't
just that Columbus sailed away
in 1492 and suddenly a
new world was discovered.
It was more that when he came
back, there was a reframing
of our understanding
of the world
and that was the
invention of America.
And I just want to point out
that this image, I just found
out the other day is actually,
it might have been done
for the Adler, I
meant to look it up,
but it's obviously an image of
earth rise from the moon done
by Chesley Bonestell, and
I think it was 1951 or '52
and it's going to be at the Air
and Space Museum, nest year.
So, they are in the
process of flattening it out
and making it look pretty
again, because it's been
in storage for a while.
But, so, O'Gorman's idea
that the old nation then
imprisoned the world
within the bounds of the
island had been overcome,
the possibility was open
of accepting as parts
of the world not only all that
is contained in our planet,
but also other planets and
any other heavenly bodies.
So, again this expansion of
our understanding of who we are
and where we are
isn't just limited
to what O'Gorman called
a lump of cosmic matter
that already existed, but
can be given a new life
and be discovered, in the case
of America, or become explored
in the case of the solar system.
And that itself is
a kind of invention.
So, in order to close the gap
between remote physical frontier
and the anticipated
imaginary frontier,
the method of discovery
needed to be a new technology
that merged the fantastic
with the scientific.
So, what we're going to talk
about today is the ability
of scientific illustration,
specifically,
the science of space art
to introduce space exploration
to reveal the future.
So that one does not need to
believe without having seen.
And our space program's
founders were pretty clear
that the space program was one
of the biggest institutionalized
acts of faith
in all of human history.
But I choose to talk about
the scientific illustration
of space art, because Bonestell
and Ley were not only able
to capture the scientific
elements of space exploration,
but also tapped into
a revitalization
of American faith
and manifest destiny.
This belief that Americans are
destined and called to explore
and settle the frontier, in this
case, the frontier of space.
And just a shout out from
everybody's favorite public
scientist, that's Carl Sagan
was one of the first to say
that Bonestell's images helped
him understand what it was he
was actually looking
at and looking for.
So, we're going to be looking at
mostly his images between 1944
and 1955 as an invitation to
explore and discover new worlds.
So, go back to 1944.
With this issue of
"Life Magazine."
It was published
on May 29, 1944,
it was a week before D-Day.
And two weeks after this issue,
this cover would feature
the very famous photos
by Robert Capa of the
Beach at Normandy.
And this issue, you can find it
online, it's pretty ordinary,
it's full of war news,
and black and white photos
of the European front.
But at the back of the issue,
there's this article titled
"Solar System" it is modelled
in miniature by Saturn,
its rings and nine moons.
And even the advertisements
in this issue reference
the war effort.
So, this article seems
a little bit off topic.
And it's actually, the
exception that proves the rule.
It is virtually the only
six pages in the magazine
that don't mention the war.
And in contrast to the issues
of black and white photos,
it's the only portion
of the magazine
to have full color pictures.
And so, the article's
purpose is revealed
in this first paragraph,
which I'm sure you can't read.
But, it promises a visit
to the planet Saturn,
where the pictures show the
changing aspect of Saturn
and its satellite
family as it would appear
to a traveler hopping towards
the planet from moon to moon.
These astronomically accurate
pictures are photo montage
paintings made by
Chesley Bonestell,
Hollywood miniature set
designed and amateur astronomer.
So, we've heard a little bit
about Bonestell yesterday.
But he actually started
his career as an architect.
That was a compromise with
his grandfather who said,
I think people have had this
conversation with their kids
from the beginning of time,
I will only pay for you to go
to college if you
do not study art,
and study something practical.
So, their compromise was
he studied architecture,
and as we'll hear, he
eventually left architecture
to become a matte
painter in Hollywood.
But he's remembered
today primarily
as the father of
modern space art.
He was born in San Francisco
in 1888, he lived until 1986.
So, he saw the whole
span of space exploration
and space science be
revealed over the course
of his almost century-long life.
And throughout that long life,
his two great loves
were art and astronomy.
And he liked to joke
to his friends
that he was an astronomer
to his architecture friends
and an architect to
his astronomer friends.
So, kind of living
between these two worlds.
And, again, he eventually
left architecture.
Probably one of his most famous
contributions to architecture
as a designer was the exterior
of the Chrysler Building
in New York City.
It's one of his better-known
projects.
But just before he
left architecture,
he worked with Joseph Strauss,
who was constructing
this mad idea for,
following through this
mad idea to put a bridge
over the Golden Gate
Street in San Francisco.
And Bonestell was recruited to
work with Joseph Strauss et.
al. Because Strauss was an
architect and an engineer.
And he couldn't explain to the
directors, i.e., the money,
where the money allocated to
the plans were supposed to go.
Strauss thought in
architectural renderings,
but Bonestell thought
in pictures.
So, Bonestell's drawings of
how the project would progress,
and you can see the
sinking of our pillars here
and the ghosted outline of
what will eventually become the
bridge, were put together to
give to the Board of Directors.
But actually, were repackaged
as a booklet that was available
to be purchased at newsstands,
called "The Golden Gate
Bridge a Technical Description
in Ordinary Language."
And I love this pamphlet because
it's Bonestell in a nutshell.
Because it's this tremendous
architectural engineering
triumph that is rendered in
these clear and really nice
to look at images that
include tiny people
that are showing kind of
the scale of the project
that is being attempted.
And this was actually
the last thing he did
in architecture more or less.
The bridge was completed in 1937
and Bonestell left San Francisco
for Hollywood to work
as a matte artist.
Before we had computers that
did a lot of things for us
and this is still skill that
shows up in some movies,
there were artists who
were skilled painters
that created backgrounds for
foregrounded live action shots.
And the matte artist's job was
to render a background
that textureless.
It was supposed to
look like the film
in which it was being
merged with.
And this is from "Citizen Kane."
This is one of the first films
that Bonestell worked on.
And a history of a book, that's
the history of matte artistry,
they actually quote
various matte artists
who still can't believe the
Bonestell managed to match
up the shadows with
the image and the door.
So, this art is still
responsible for some
of our favorite, well my
favorite scenes in films
and it's still considered
a very technical
and very important skill today.
But, again one of the first
films that Bonestell worked
on was "Citizen Cane" and he
was particularly interested
in Orson Wells opening
shot of Xanadu,
which is Charles
Foster Cane's castle.
It begins at the gates of the
castle, and through a series
of dissolves we move, some
people probably remember this,
we move through the
gardens, then to the zoo,
then to the front door.
And then we kind of float up to
the window of Cane's bedroom.
And in each shot, the castle
gets bigger as we get closer
to it but maintains
its aspect ratio.
In other words, it
illustrates a journey.
And this is what gave
Bonestell the idea
for a journey to
the plant Saturn.
Because as a fan of astronomy,
he's been incredibly frustrated
with the current
status of space art.
It was either scientifically
correct, but maybe not
that lively to look at.
Or it was fantastically lively,
and moderately inaccurate.
So, he wanted to use
his technical skill
as an architectural designer
and his artistic skill
as a matte artist to do his
own version of space art
and essentially improve
on techniques
that people had used before.
So, this is why life promises
us a visit to the planet Saturn,
even ending on the
planet's surface.
So, we start out
on a tiny Phoebe
where Saturn is still far
away, but the view of Saturn
from Phoebe is almost exactly
proportional to the perspective
of the moon seen from earth.
And, at this point,
Phoebe was thought
to be Saturn's most
distant moon,
we now know that
that's not true.
But, from there we move
to Lapetus , where,
please note we have tiny
explorers here toddling
around the canyons there.
And then, the one-two of
them all, the Saturn scene
from Titan, which is probably
not only Saturn's best-known
moon, but this image made
it into your program,
this is almost definitely
Bonestell's best-known painting,
and another artist actually
called it the painting
that launched 1000 careers.
Because so many people, like
Carl Sagan were inspired
to become astronomers,
astrophysicists, astronauts,
engineers, space artists.
And ironically, Carl
Sagan was one
of the scientists
responsible for the discovery
that Titan's atmosphere
is actually opaque,
so you would never have
this view to begin with.
So, oh well.
From there we go to Dione,
which is known for its volcanos.
So, we're looking at Saturn
from inside of a lava tube.
Our last moon is Mimas,
where Saturn is so close
that it fills the entire sky.
And you can actually see
the shadow of Dione there
and the shadow of the rings
being cast on the side.
And finally, we go to
the surface of Saturn.
We're actually looking up
through the methane clouds.
Standing just a few degrees
north of the equator.
And to get this perspective,
Bonestell stood himself
at 15.5 degrees latitude in
Saturn's northern hemisphere.
And as Willy Ley later
explained, if you were on earth
and wanted this view of Saturn's
rings, all you would have
to do is go to Guatemala
and look up.
And this is an image
by Ron Miller.
He's a contemporary
space artist.
But what was perhaps the
most extraordinary element
of the paintings was
the stylistic choice
that enchanted Bonestell's
first admirers.
So, in the foreground of two
of these paintings as we saw,
there are tiny people.
They first appear
here on Lapetus.
They are also again on Mimas.
And they're wearing spacesuits
that are pretty prescient
for 1944.
They shielded helmets
and oxygen packs.
And all five of these figures
are depicted inspecting this
rocky new frontier.
So, even though one very
unimaginative editor
at "Life" felt to explain
that they were put there
for perspective, what Bonestell
was doing was adding more
than perspective.
He was brought back to life the
Hudson River School of painting,
an artistic movement that
faded with the closing
of the Western frontier.
And Bonestell's assertions that
his paintings were based on fact
and not fiction placed
in the legacy
of these romantic landscapes of
the 19th century of painting.
And has actually led some
to call Bonestell the
last Hudson Valley River
School artist.
So, beginning in the
Hudson River Valley,
which the father is
considered to be Thomas Cole.
In the decades leading into
and out of the Civil War,
these paintings evolved
with the time
to share the cultural enthusiasm
for exploration and expansion,
but also expressed a
nationalistic belief
that nature was both a source of
spiritual renewal and a location
of cultural and national
identity.
And here we have this is
actually the explorer Ferdinand
Hayden and presumably a
Native American guide standing
on the edge of the Grand
Canyon of the Yellowstone.
And of course, you can see this
painting just down the road.
But we know Bonestell was
a fan, or we can conjecture
that he was a fan because he
frequently reproduced elements
of those paintings in his own.
And this is from another
article in "Life Magazine"
about the origins of the earth.
But the scope of Bonestell's
paintings of Saturn's moons
and the diminutive foregrounded
figures set against a backdrop
of a frontier are
tropes in these paintings
of the American west
made by some
of the school's most famous
artists, such as Thomas Hill,
Frederick Edwin Church,
Albert Bierstadt's.
Note the tiny train coming
through the mountain there.
And especially Thomas Moran.
But I just wanted to
show really quick.
So, this is an image that
Bonestell did in 1949,
the same year that the
"Conquest of Space" came out.
And this gentleman in the red
shirt here is actually Chesley
Bonestell, Right.
So, a little picture of home.
So, artists like Moran travelled
with government research teams
to explore the Yellowstone,
the Grand Canyon, the Rockies.
And brought back
landscapes of vast panoramas,
which included scientifically
precise renderings
of regional flora and geology.
And Moran's images
were significant,
not only because they encouraged
further scientific study,
and ultimately the preservation
of places like the Yellowstone
for their remarkable scientific
curiosities full for freaks
and phenomena of nature.
But also, because they
revitalized the sense
of a calling to settle and
explore that had been lost
in the spiritual
crisis of the Civil War.
And that spiritual crisis
was answered with calls
to explore God's new
Israel, in the language
of many of these proponents.
And double down on
their sense of a faith
and a calling to
conquer frontier.
But in the same way
that Moran's paintings
of the western frontier
comforted a nation unsure
of their next step
after the Civil War,
Bonestell's images were a step
towards revitalizing a sense
of faith and calling, and
an evocation of a nostalgia
for the exploration of
the western frontier.
And actually to show viewers
something beyond the horizon
of the Second World War,
this is actually a quote
from a gentleman from Ohio,
writing letter to the editor
about three weeks after
these images appeared
in "Life" saying, "If mankind
in its frenzy should succeed
in utterly destroying itself,
the destruction would create not
so much as a ripple
in the great universe
of which we are only
an insignificant part.
May "Life" publish more about
the universe that we may learn
from its law and
order to avoid war.
And they also arguably,
these paintings,
evoke what Elizabeth Kessler
calls the astronomical sublime.
An extreme aesthetic experience
that threatens to overwhelm even
as it affirms humanity
potential.
If it makes us feel
small but connected
to a larger and wider universe.
And apparently, "Life"
realized that that was true
of these paintings, because they
paid Bonestell the equivalent
of about
a-quarter-of-a-million-dollars
today for the rights to them.
But these paintings
set Bonestell on a path
that eventually led
him to our other hero
for the day, Willy Ley.
He was born in Berlin in 1906
with a passion for exploration.
And he actually recounts
in one of his books
that when a teacher asks,
an elementary school teacher
asked them what they wanted
to be when they're grown
and why, he said he wanted
to be an explorer and the
teacher said that's not a
real profession.
Think of something else.
But Ley was undeterred.
He was actually, as he
described it, born in the shadow
of the Museum of Natural
History in Berlin.
And he spent his whole life look
especially into as he put it,
such corners as others
had neglected
through the natural
sciences and physics.
And when he went to university,
he couldn't actually figure
out what he wanted to study
and he took on subjects ranging
from astronomy to zoology,
which sounds like a bad joke.
But was actually what
he was trying to study.
But his curiosity and passion
eventually took him beyond the
neglected corners of science
and even beyond the
ends of the earth.
And he, at the age of 20,
published his first book,
"The Journey into Space."
That was the first of many books
written by Ley that attempted
to translate a dense
and convoluted science
for an ordinary reader.
So, he was taking other things
that were being published
at the time that were basically
just equations and turning it
into a narrative that anybody
could pick up and understand.
And his first book
was successful enough
that he was asked by Fritz
Lang, the writer and director
of the 1927 film,
"Metropolis" to act
as a technological
consultant for his new film,
"Woman in the Moon," or,
"By Rocket to the
Moon" at the age of 23.
So, that's pretty decent.
But, Ley eventually
came to America in 1934.
He had been one of the founders
of Germany's famous
Spaceflight Society
that would eventually be sort
of subsumed into the German Army
and start building V-2 rockets.
And he left, in part, because
he was of Jewish heritage.
But also, because he
was dismayed by the idea
that these beautiful rockets
that he was helping build
and design were going
to be used as weapons.
That wasn't really
what he wanted to do.
So, he moved to the US
to begin his career again
as a science writer
and journalist.
And his first and most
famous books were about,
as he called them
exotic zoology.
But by far, the best
seller published in English
in the 1940s was his, I believe
it was a 1942 book, "Rocket,
Missiles and Space Travel."
When it first came out,
nobody was very interested,
aside from a small select group
of people were very
interested in rockets.
About three months after
the book premiered,
Germany had their
first successful test
of the V-2 rocket, and suddenly
everybody was very interested
in how rockets worked.
And this became an
overnight best-seller.
And made him very famous,
but even though he was
suddenly asked to write about
and to give interviews on
the purpose of rockets,
he refused to say that they
were solely for the purpose
of blowing up London and Paris.
That actually after the
war, everybody would see
that we would be able
to use these rockets
to explore our solar system.
That they weren't a weapon, they
were a mode of transportation.
So, in 1945, "Mechanics
Illustrated" asked him
to essentially tell
us how this will work.
How would we take a
rocket to the moon.
And they said, we'll
get you somebody
to illustrate this,
so it makes sense.
And this is how Ley
and Bonestell met.
So, this is the first
article of the feature.
Ley's prose with
Bonestell's paintings.
And Bonestell actually later,
it's the favorite theme
of science fiction is no
longer fantasy, latest advances
in rocket research will
make space exploration a
distinct possibility.
So, again this idea that
rockets will be the way
in which we get to the moon.
And moving beyond what
he did for the magazine,
Bonestell actually created, with
Ley's help, he created a trip
to the moon that
begins on earth,
kind of slingshots us toward the
moon, comes in for a landing,
over Aristarchus crater.
And lands not too far
away from Mounts Pico.
And points out that the
landscape is broken rock
because there's no water
to erode river valleys.
But, and here we have
a very hard to see,
but there are explorers again.
Yes, the moon is not this
mountainous, but it makes
for a lovely picture to think
that this is what it looks like.
But, what was especially
significant,
or I think significant about
this particular journey was
that it's easy to forget
that at this point,
no human had seen this view.
We were still, about a
decade away from some
of the first satellite images of
the earth surrounded by space.
And it would be another
25 years before the crew
of Apollo 15 took
this image in 1972.
And it's accurate, we'll say all
but for the upside-down martini
glass, this maybe not part
of the original Apollo Mission.
But, Bonestell had
eventually become so in demand
that he left, more or less,
working in Hollywood and began
to produce so many
images that they became,
reached a critical mass.
He didn't know what
to do with them.
A friend suggested why
don't you write a book
with your friend
and mine, Willy Ley.
So, the two of them worked
out that the book
would be a guided tour
of the solar system by rocket.
So, in chapter 2 Ley tells us,
we are in New Mexico
waiting for liftoff.
We're going to use
the Earth's gravity
to slingshot ourselves
towards the moon.
And here, we're flying
over New York City.
You can see Central
Park down there.
We will reach the moon and
spend a week or two there
to explore a little bit.
And this image became pretty
iconic when it was more
or less the inspiration
for George Pal's science fiction
classic, "Destination Moon."
He even borrowed the
rocket, named it Luna
and asked Chesley Bonestell
to do the background.
And my favorite thing about
this film is that it ends
with the title card, this
is the end of the beginning.
So, this is just our
first dip into space.
But back to our explorers
in the conquest of space.
They are, again, spending some
time getting to know the surface
of the moon, making
astonishing discoveries
in the surface of rock there.
But, because there's
less gravity
on the moon it is
easier to create liftoff.
The plane of the solar system is
such that it allows us to move
around the sun and go
land on sunny Mercury,
where the temperatures
are so high,
that our visiting explorers are
forced to wear asbestos suits.
Because we should all
wear our asbestos suits
when we go to Mercury.
We then pass through
Venus' dust bowl,
where actually earth
is the morning star.
You can see the morning
star right there.
We hop right over the earth
and head to the moons of Mars,
pour a little [inaudible]
before heading
down to tour the
famous canals of Mars.
And this image in the book
is accompanied by the note
that it was check for color by
Dr. Edison Petit of Mount Wilson
and Palomar Observatories.
So, again the idea that we
are using the best scientific
knowledge at our hands in
order to create these images.
But from Mars, Ley takes what he
tells the reader is beyond the
realm of the dwarves,
earth, Mars, etcetera,
where just as the
fairytales always existed,
there's the kingdom
of the giants.
So, our first stop is
the moons of Jupiter.
I think this is Europa.
And then we head to the surface
of Jupiter, which his depicted
as frothy with hydrogen,
lava, and liquid ammonia.
After, we go to Saturn, same
images appear in conquest
of space as were
in "Life Magazine."
Then we go to Uranus, Neptune,
and then out to lonely
little Pluto,
back when it was still a plant.
Before it was fired.
That is so far away from
our son, that it appears
as only a slightly larger
star on the horizon.
And, this jaunt around the solar
system led the Robert Heinlein
in review for the Saturday
Review of Literature
to have jokingly, half sincerely
call this book the Baedeker
of the solar system.
It was a huge bestseller.
And in thinking about,
not only its purpose,
but also its effect,
it reminded me,
and I think it's reminded
others of Captain Cook's voyage
in 1768, when he took
a long naturalist
with him named Joseph Banks
who was only 24 years old.
He volunteered to accompany
the crew and came back
with an entire ship stuffed with
plants, flowers, fish, insects,
birds, mammals, reptiles,
shells, rocks.
He returned back to London to
unpack and catalog these foils
and to eventually
publish his journals.
So, his narrative of his time in
a place that nobody in England,
for the most part,
would ever see.
But the apophysis
of his collection,
actually was nearly a
thousand botanical paintings
by Sydney Parkinson, a
young Scottish Quaker artist
who accompanied the voyage.
Banks also created almost 1400
drawings of plants that went
on to be published separately.
But what Parkinson and Banks
did was bring back these images
of Pacific Islanders, of
new harbors, new horizons.
And brought back a new world
that was invented again
through the process of
interpretation of the hordes
of information that Banks
stowed away in his house.
So, the books and discoveries
that came from Bank's collection
and Parkinson's drawings
proliferated
and popularized the
pursuit of natural history.
Both as a calling unto itself
and as an accumulation of facts,
figures, statistics,
characteristics,
and data from around
the natural world.
In short, what Banks et.
al did was become what historian
Richard Holms calls in his book,
"The Age of Wonder" a kind
of chorus figure or guide.
A scientific Virgil, who
was warning young men
and some women away
from the life
of a quiet country gentlemen
and encouraging them to go out
and see new life and new
places for themselves.
So, he ended up becoming; Banks
ended up becoming an example
to the young curious,
passionate explorers
of a generation of
his disciples.
And this was more or less
the effect that the conquest
of space had on a
generation of people in 1949,
when it was first published.
They had grown up,
more or less in shadow
of two great World Wars
and the Depression.
And to see these new horizons,
served as an incredible source
of excitement and
hope for the future.
And Ben Bova, a very well-known
science fiction writer said
that as a strong league writer,
"it was as if Bonestell had gone
out to Mars and the
moons of Saturn
to survey the territory
I wanted to write
about long before the
first spacecraft arose
from Earth's surface, Bonestell
had been there and his vision
of these worlds is still the
most vivid, the freshest,
the one that excites
me even now."
Arthur C. Clarke in a
contemporary review of;
Clarke and Bonestell would
actually publish together
at one point, but he was
relatively unknown at the time,
or becoming better known.
And in a review for the
Saturday Review of Literature,
I think it was he said,
Mr. Bonestell's remarkable
technique,
produces an effective
realism so striking
that his paintings have
often been mistaken
for actual color photographs
by those slightly unacquainted
with the present status
of interplanetary flight.
So, and here are brave
explorers hopping
around in the low gravity
of one of Mars' moons.
But, the book made
Ley very famous,
made Bonestell very famous.
And Ley used some of this
momentum to work with other,
again, space evangelists
to put together a series
for "Collier's Magazine."
And it was a series of articles
that ran from 1952 until 1954.
Included people like the great
ringmaster himself, von Braun.
There's Bonestell, there's Ley.
There was also the
astronomer Fred Whipple,
physicist Joseph Caplan,
Heinz Haber a medical doctor.
And they all, for this
first issue wrote a series
of articles, each a
couple thousand words.
And the premiere
issue was titled,
"Man Will Conquer
Space Soon," and opens
with an editorial titled,
"What are we waiting for?"
And the short introduction
asserts
that on the following pages,
Collier's presents the story
of the inevitability of
man's conquest of space.
What you will read here is
not science fiction it is
serious fact.
And so, with that begin our
hearing into the wilderness
with van Braun's article,
"Crossing the Last Frontier."
And the title itself is one of
just a dozen references to space
as the last frontier a
literal space for civilization,
settlement and technological
conquest.
Von Braun closes the
article by explaining
that Americans are ready for
a journey to "man's oldest
and last frontier, the
heavens themselves."
Ley, wrote on the topic of
one of his favorite inventions
which was the space station.
If this looks familiar, it's
because it was the inspiration
for the space station in
2001, "A Space Odyssey."
But he actually uses his
article to explain not only
that this station will
be a useful platform
for acquiring scientific
knowledge,
but that it is also a good
position from which to move
from Earth's orbit out
to the other planets
to continue to explore.
And this image is by [inaudible]
it's not Chesley Bonestell, but.
The next issue, in October 1952
is about a trip to the moon,
and it begins with this fleet
of three cargo ships carrying
between 10 and 20
crewmembers a piece.
The ship is actually meant
to be assembled in space.
And features some of the ships
from the original article
and the space station
kind of hovering nearby
as the finishing touches
are put on the lunar ship.
So, we have our space station,
this is from the
original article.
These are space taxis that are
bringing our crew up to work on
and assemble their ships that
will take them to the moon,
where they will land and set
about exploring for
about six weeks.
They will turn the ships
into essentially habitats
and from them will emerge,
their transport vehicles
that will take them all
over the lunar surface.
And they'll actually leave
these, according to the plan,
they will leave some
of these things there
for the next expedition
to the moon.
And I love this image
on the right,
because it is just
indisputably prophetic.
This is the Eagle taking
off from the surface
of the moon, 17 years later.
So, after further issues dealing
with the practical questions
of how humans will fare in
space, "Collier's" turns
to humanity's most ambitious
endeavor yet, to Mars.
So, on April 30, 1954,
von Braun's article,
"Can We Get to Mars?"
was the anchor piece in
a three-article issue
on the exploration
of the red planet.
And in the two-page spread,
we have the Mars fleet
assembling 1075 miles
above the earth.
And there is our space station,
and again, our space taxis.
They ready themselves to
again slingshot themselves
around the earth, head out to
Mars, where they reassemble
above the Martian surface.
And descend to land on
the north pole of Mars.
And will drive down
to create habitats,
which will be their base
while they are exploring Mars.
And less we forget to pay
our debt, there's plenty
of Bonestell to go around, and
continue to inspire us all.
This is from "The Martian,"
The 2015 Ridley Scott film.
And I said that that
image of Saturn seen
from Titan is the most
famous Bonestell image,
it actually shows
up in the movie.
You can kind of see it
behind Sean Bean's head.
It's in the head
of NASA's office,
hanging there on the wall.
But, again, inspirations
reassert themselves
through generations.
This final image, if it will
ever come up, when it appeared
in "Collier's" in 1954,
summed up the hope not just
for a space program,
but for a new frontier.
Weapons have become ships
and heroes are geologists.
We've taken technology
and science
to their furthest points.
You can see this image in the
Air and Space Museum there.
And you can see this
image across the street.
This is one of Moran's paintings
that I think is pretty
unmistakable image represented
in the Mars image.
The "Collier's" series of
articles didn't just inspire
"Collier's" readers, it
actually inspired Walt Disney,
who had been looking for content
for the Tomorrowland portion
of his new amusement park.
And, his producer Ward
Kimball suggested that he look
at the "Collier's" articles.
So, over the next two years,
Disney & Company
produced a series
of centrally live-action
versions of these articles
that stared von Braun,
Ley and Heinz Haber.
The first is "Man in Space," in
1955 it was earlier in the year.
And there is Haber,
von Braun, and Ley.
It was followed, at the end of
the year with "Man in the Moon"
about the first excursion
to the moon
and this is Ley's space station
redesigned so they wouldn't get
into trouble with "Collier'"
for reproducing that.
But, and eventually,
Frontierland and its mirror
of Tomorrowland mirrored across
each other, would be anchored
by their respective
forts, and by the rocket
that Ley helped Disney
& Company design for it.
With a little ride that you
could go on a trip to the moon,
around the moon, and on the back
of the moon there was some
kind of alien base there.
And yeah. Everybody's
favorite trip to the moon.
But two years after
the Disney's specials
and the "Collier's" articles,
theologian Paul Tillich wrote
in his famous book that
"man is driven toward faith
by his awareness of the
infinite to which he belongs.
An active of faith is an act of
a finite being who is grasped by
and turned to the infinite.
So, what I love and find myself
wondering is the invention
of space an example
of being grasped by
and tuned to the infinite.
Essentially, is the exploration
of faith an act of faith
by an finite being
here on this earth,
looking for new frontiers?
Because in the same way
that 19th century Americans
couldn't support expansionism
or believe in manifest destiny
before they had seen the
frontier rendered by
artists like Moran.
Twentieth century Americans
couldn't believe their new
frontier or the value of space
exploration without Saturn seen
from Titan, or the
surface of Mars.
But the question my work picks
up on is is the imagining
of space something that
can be revitalized again?
And on August 12, 2012, the
whole world, more or less,
tuned in to watch what NASA had
billed at 7 minutes of terror.
In a highly produced,
animated short,
the landing of the Curiosity
rover on the surface of Mars
by a sky crane, very James Bond,
had circulated on social media,
introducing the global public,
not only to the lander's
purpose, but the planet
for which it was
designed to explore.
And this image was the first one
that went live on the Internet.
Curiosity has its own Twitter;
his, her own Twitter feed.
And so, this image of
her foot, some said,
was the substance
of things hoped for.
And there was much rejoicing,
not just amongst the scientists,
but also amongst the public.
And I just have to say I love
this guy's face right there.
These are people who
spontaneously gathered
in Time Square in New
York City to listen
to essentially the broadcast
that was happening rom the jet
propulsion lab in California,
after having watched
this animated version
of Curiosity landing on Mars.
And when the rover was
said to have landed,
and that Tweet went
live of the foot
of the rover the whole group
just exploded with joy,
and apparently started chanting
things like "NASA, NASA,"
and "science, science."
But for me, what I
think is exciting is
that it's an expression of
collective effervescence,
in which an entire tribe joins
together to celebrate a totem,
in this case Curiosity,
which then becomes sacred
through the collective
gathering of the clan.
So, I think scientific
illustration can help the whole
world partake ng of the claim
world in science and
space exploration
and in a new frontier.
So, oh, that was our
friend Curiosity.
By situating his
paintings in the tradition
of the Hudson River School,
Bonestell connected his project
to that of artists like Moran,
who illuminated the Western
frontier in the previous .
And perhaps Ley's desire
to explore space revitalized
the sense of the calling
to explore these new
frontiers in new ways
such as sending rovers
like Curiosity
to the surface of other planets.
So, I believe Ley and Bonestell
illustrate the way in which,
as they would put it,
ideas become effective
forces in history.
They created an enthusiasm
for the frontier so powerful
that just 25 years
after Bonestell's images
of Saturn appeared
in "Life Magazine,"
two Americans walked
on the moon.
America's faith was rewarded,
the frontier had been conquered.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.